[Music]
what we got today Jim t-shirts t-shirts
Aaron what do you get what we got in
here we got it what looks like a simple
Navy t-shirt well it's a pocket tee the
neck is a little bit stretched out or
not too extreme you notice the rib on
the neck is a little bit thinner the
sleeves are perfect if you've got a
tighter shorter sleeve it's gonna give
the illusion that you have bigger guns
than you do I mean I don't have guns
like Aaron but I like my t-shirts short
if you've got guns like why not sort of
show me I need to walk around like Lou
Ferrigno this length is perfect cuz it
coming right to the waist and right
hands most t-shirts are cut down and
look like you're wearing a house jacket
like you like your grandma Joe mm-hmm
you don't you do with those t-shirts
what did you purge out the window
some are spring cleaning get them out of
here also just to remember t-shirt is
something you've got to try on you think
you've got to try on your suits but you
think oh I'm a medium I'm an extra-large
I can just grab one yeah we're talking
about fit even though it's just a
t-shirt just like a dress shirt a
t-shirt that you will and that's the
point of today's video we got a very
different t-shirt look here I think as
soon as the guy thinks about a t-shirt
or suit check and he thinks oh I'm gonna
wear like some great rocker T which is
great but sometimes that rocker T is
left over from college days learn and
it's more of a tunic than a t-shirt so
we're doing exactly as it has a
stretched out crew neck and I even like
to give the neck a little bit of tug
riles one of your style see I like to
break the banding a little bit love the
way these two Gray's match up together
the heather gray which is a little bit
thick but it's sophisticated with it
with the great cotton suit there's a
slight drape to it but it's but it
doesn't great way to see you can say
this cut slim to the body t-shirt you
think it's a very simple basic item in
fact there are some secrets to it and
some rules about it it's fit to a teeth
HHA there we go see even the coiny jokes
they still work thanks for watching
[Music]
you